hi dr. Wallach thank you for taking my
call me God always bless you and your
family thank you very kind
I feel very privileged I'm blessed to
have this happiness opportunity to speak
with you I'm 37 years old I weighed 300
pounds
I have always battled with a hormonal
imbalance and I started my period around
the age of 13 I've had irregular cycles
and when I'd go to the doctor about it
they'd say maybe when I turned 16 I'd
have a regular cycle mm-hmm that wasn't
the case when I was 18 I went back still
with the same problem and they
suggested birth control pills I didn't
agree do you have you had children no I
haven't okay no did you say you're 200
pounds or 300 pounds 300 pounds and how
tall are you
I'm five five okay all right you have
any other issues any public pressure
diabetes arthritis no I don't have
diabetes I did I went back to the doctor
recently because he saw my cycles were
regular I wasn't getting them now I went
back because I'm getting them too
frequently very often and they found
that I have a tumor in my uterus and
recommended that I had a hysterectomy a
full hysterectomy to get rid of my job
you know is his tumor is this a fibroid
tumor or is it a malignancy well they
weren't able to tell me because they
said only once they take out the tumor
they'll know if it's malignant but they
said that when they did find after the
exam that they do did they just found
find some white blood cells and some
cancer cells okay
right so let's hold on hear from her are
you there I'm here okay here's our
friend Mary she's five foot five and
said Craig five foot five and it weighs
300 pounds
she had PMS you know problems most of
her life hormonal imbalances and so
forth plus the weight challenge and what
would you do for her she got tumors now
so we have to be careful what we suggest
and so will you do to suggest to support
our immune system so that I'd stay away
from the hormone thing right now okay
because we don't know what type of tumor
it is because hormone supplements can
drive cancer so we want to stay away
from hormone supplements what would you
give her to support of immune system
cause when you have cancer of any type
I would definitely your immune system is
your best friend right well for what
things with her weight and everything
one of the reasons she got the way
problem is because she needs to get on a
gluten-free diet very good creating
contributing to the weight problem and
with for her issues she really needs
three healthy brain and heart packs and
then I would also suggest she takes a
zero fam and the woman's FX and also the
few Koide z4 you know to build her
immune system
yeah well I'm gonna stay away from the
zero feminists and the woman's effects
because those are hormone pushing things
and so but I wouldn't I do like to like
the easy radical okay - I go with a
minimum of two optimally three healthy
brain and heart attacks or month is
gonna give her the nutrients she needs
to support mewn system and provide for
all the normal physiology also Zee
radical she could have three ounces of
data three quarts a month great
antioxidants you have an ounce of
breakfast ounce of lunch at dinnertime
and then what you do to help her with
the weight loss obviously the reve reve
yes and so she needs to go on two
bottles of Rev per month clear dropper
flow under her tongue thirty minutes for
each meal they absorb their old tissues
and for a second
drop her full under her tongue 15 this
brings me a little tissue mm
let off and she should start to lose a
hand pump two pounds a day and when you
get your decision what you're going to
do here about the surgery or no surgery
that's up to you we can't give you an
advice for that but whatever you decide
if they wanted to biopsy or they just
want to take your uterus out whatever
you wanted to and when they make a
diagnosis of this lump or mass or tumor
whatever's going on inside theaters then
give us a call again so we can actually
be more specific on that piece let's go
this direction and keep us informed and
once they've done what they've done it
makes a they make a specific diagnosis
we'll be able to help you more
specifically but this is a great start